[Music]
it seemed as though they had emerged
from a tunnel
the overhanging trees thinned to nothing
and suddenly they were under the open
sky and the causeway was a flat ribbon
before them
puddles from the earlier storm reflected
a sliver of moon
it's too bad we couldn't see it in the
daylight adam said
bonnie smiled and crumpled an empty
candy wrapper in her hand
plenty of time for that besides i sort
of like it
seems like we're driving off the end of
the earth the walmart a couple miles
back kind of spoils that illusion
adam pointed out and bonnie laughed in
the glow from the headlights they could
just begin to make
out the dark speck of tree choked land
ahead suspended like a lily pad
on a black expanse of water the lights
of the houses between the trees had just
begun to come into view
when there was a vague movement just
past the far right edge of the
headlight's cone
was that a deer bonnie said it looked
like a person
adam stopped the car and shifted into
reverse the darkness behind them was
like an enormous hole
huh why are they walking out here in the
rain maybe they broke down somewhere
we'd better make sure they could be hurt
or something
adam backed up and stopped and bonnie
rolled down her window and peered into
the night
i don't see anyone she said he leaned
across her lap and squinted
oh there look i backed up too far he
inched the car forward until they could
both see a slight figure
clad in a dark jacket and pants walking
very slowly along the rocky shoulder
hey hi adam called everything all right
do you need a lift somewhere
the figure turned toward them and in the
reflected moonlight they could make out
the pale round face of a girl
perhaps in her late teens or early
twenties with curly dark hair partially
tucked beneath the hood of her jacket
she smiled oh hi no i'm all right just
heading back
you live on the island bonnie asked
not really just visiting she was swaying
a little as she stood there
and bonnie wondered if she was drunk hop
in we can drop you off
it's pretty wet out here said adam
really that's okay
i like being out besides i don't want to
attract any attention coming back
she laughed then a soft warble like the
coup of a bird you sure
adam said we're heading that way and
it's no trouble
thanks but i'll make it you're adam and
bonnie right
the couple in the car exchanged surprise
glances how did you know that
bonnie said the girl shrugged just heard
you were coming
notorious already i guess adam said
what's your name
marie i should really get back though
bonnie leaned farther out of her window
i feel bad just leaving you on the side
of the road
she could barely make out the girl's
features her eyes were mere glimpse
beneath her hood
the swaying seemed to have intensified
and bonnie noticed marie's head shift
ever so slightly toward the island
as though she was eager to be on the
move i don't have far to go
well maybe we'll see you around adam
said relaxing back into the driver's
seat
you may but you didn't see me this time
okay
she laughed her bird laugh again your
secret's safe with us
said bonnie the car pulled away and she
watched in her side mirror as the girl's
figure receded into the distance
after a few seconds it seemed as though
the darkness had swallowed her
adam clad only in boxer shorts and a
loose black t-shirt
patted out onto the patio in his bare
feet a mug of coffee in each hand
bonnie took one from him and smiled as
he sat down in the rattan chair next to
hers
you're right i guess it is prettier in
the daytime she said
finch island was an island only in name
a mere scrap of rock in the middle of a
small lake
its five houses had once been part of a
single compound
owned by the industrialist finch family
in the early 20th century
the house that adam and bonnie had
rented for the week was on the end of
the island farthest from the causeway
and had once been a guest house for the
finch family's servants
the back patio afforded a miss softened
view of the opposite mainland
less than a mile distant i think i'm in
vacation mood already
adam said extending his long legs and
propping his feet on the patio railing
nice for you bonnie said poking him in
the ribs
don't stress bon you'll get it
interview's not until tomorrow so let's
just forget about it and relax for the
day
maybe explore the island later i'd like
that
shame we can't afford to buy this place
it's quiet out here
well if you get that job maybe we can
talk but meantime just enjoy it while
we're here
even if we did buy it you'd be sick of
the commute inside of a day
he reached over and stroked her cheek
with his finger
i know and the quiet would drive me
crazy she laughed and sipped her coffee
as she stared across the water
i wonder if we'll meet any of the
neighbors while we're here
god i hope not you know how people are
when they live on tiny islands
always sticking their noses into their
neighbor's business i just wanted to
have a peaceful week with you and
copious amounts of alcohol and sex
oh we'll make that happen neighbors be
damned bonnie said with a grin
after a moment she went thoughtful again
i hope marie got home all right
she said i guess she knew where she was
going
said adam probably just snuck out to see
her boyfriend or something and trying to
get back in the house without her
parents seeing her
probably bonnie finished off her coffee
and unfurled from her chair
stretching like a cat let's get dressed
and take a walk around before it gets
too warm
it took less than 45 minutes to make a
circuit of the entire island
and in that time they saw not a single
other soul
the other four houses were arranged in a
rough horseshoe pattern
though little could be seen of the
actual structures through the thick
foliage
often the only way to tell there was a
house among the trees was the presence
of a driveway and a neat silver mailbox
it was at one of these mailboxes at the
house next door to theirs that they
spotted their first permanent island
inhabitant
in the form of a short blonde woman with
a pert upturned nose
and a spray of freckles across her tan
cheeks
she stood at the end of her driveway
mail in hand and watched them approach
i wondered when you'd be arriving she
said when they were close enough to hear
her
i'd heard you were coming yesterday we
got hung up in the storm on the way here
adam said already extending his hand as
he walked
we got in late last night adam powell
this is my wife bonnie
nice to meet you deb mueller and my
husband jim is around here somewhere
how do you like finch island so far it's
beautiful
bonnie said i almost wish we were
staying longer than a week
well it's like anywhere else different
when you live here
jim and i have only been here six months
and he loves it but it's also kind of
she waved the hand containing her mail
around in a circle i don't know
isolating maybe hey you two want to come
in for some tea or lunch or something
i made a ton of chicken salad and i
can't give this stuff away
adam squeezed bonnie's hand as if to say
uh-oh it started already
but then he said sure we can't stay long
though oh i know i know
i don't mean to intrude on your vacation
or anything but i haven't seen any new
people in months you understand
she began to retreat up the driveway her
sandals flopping against her heels
i'll only keep you long enough for a
sandwich and some gossip i promise
adam and bonnie exchanged a smile and an
eye roll and followed deb to the house
tea soon gave way to wine even though
the sun still hung high above the
horizon
[ __ ] it said deb as she poured a second
large glass for herself and one for
bonnie
adam declined a refill i'm not really
sure what it is
deb was saying taking a bite from her
sandwich and licking her fingers
things have been weird since we moved
here
weird how bonnie asked she had finished
her sandwich and now sat rapidly with
her elbows on the table
top i don't know jim is acting sort of
strange
i've talked to the others that's jillian
and sue they've lived on the island
longer than we have
they told me the same thing that their
husbands went weird a little while ago
and then on top of that there's marcus
who's that
adam asked deb took a generous slug from
her wine glass
he's the freak who lives in that small
house out nearest the causeway
you probably wouldn't have seen him i
shouldn't pick on him because he's sort
of pitiful but he's really the worst
bonnie leaned in closer her eyes were
slightly glassy
worst god he's just a kid really
i don't think he's any more than 19 or
so i think he's sort of
[ __ ] can i say that not like
[ __ ] [ __ ] but you know
slow plus he has something wrong with
his face
no one sees him much he just stays in
that house most of the time
i think he's tried to skeeve on every
woman on the island at some point or
another always mooning around
sue said he was peeking in her windows
once like a pervert
jillian told me he was bad before but
he's gotten a lot bolder since his
parents died
he seems harmless but ugh she shuddered
how did the parents die adam was sitting
back in his chair with his arms crossed
some kind of boat accident i think about
a year ago
bonnie finished off her wine and the
people who lived in our house
deb waved a dismissive hand they were
old lived here since the big bang
probably
they died about a month back both on the
same day heart attacks i guess
happens that way with old couples
sometimes doesn't it
they died in our house bonnie's lip
curled yeah but what can you do
at least one person's probably died in
every house on the island
like i said they were old their ghosts
wouldn't cause you much trouble i
wouldn't think
she snorted laughter and after a moment
both adam and bonnie joined in
when the mirth had subsided a brief
silence prompted adam to rise from his
seat
well thanks very much for lunch and for
the company we should probably be
getting back
bonnie's got an interview tomorrow and i
expect she wants to get prepared for it
he glanced at his wife encouragingly
bonnie rose too
yeah i really should start getting my
[ __ ] together thanks so much for
everything
and hey we'd really like it if you and
your husband came and had dinner with us
tomorrow night to return the favor
adam said deb raised her empty glass at
him
sure i'd love that just give me a shout
about the time
no problem adam and bonnie made their
way toward the door
and deb followed a few steps behind
wavering a little on her feet
from below them there came an odd
creaking sound and then a faint scuttle
adam stopped and turned what was that
lord knows deb replied rats more than
likely
or jim might be creeping around in the
basement for some reason never can tell
what he's up to
her expression darkened for a second but
it passed quickly
well thanks again bonnie opened the
front door and stepped out onto the
porch
adam followed but then bonnie paused
maybe i shouldn't say anything
but do you know a girl named marie young
pretty dark curly hair
deb tilted her head doesn't ring a bell
she doesn't live on the island
well it was nothing really we just saw
her on the causeway on the night we got
here
she told us she was visiting as she
spoke adam's hand crept into hers and he
squeezed it tightly
huh i don't know who that could have
been unless marcus is hiding a
girlfriend over there
not bloody likely another snort
anyway well we'll see you tomorrow
bonnie smiled and stepped off the porch
adam close behind her see you then said
deb
and close the door with a definitive
slam
bonnie glanced at adam's reflection
behind her in the mirror
hair up or down she asked you look great
either way
he laughed when she narrowed her eyes at
him okay down
minutes later bonnie was picking her
purse up off the bed and smoothing her
blouse
presentable more than you'll do fine
that's what i keep telling myself don't
get into too much trouble while i'm gone
i won't i think i'm just gonna prep some
stuff for dinner and then chill on the
patio with a beer
sounds good see you soon and i can join
you yep
break a leg love you bon he kissed her
on the cheek
back at you adam watched from the window
and waved as bonnie back the car out of
the driveway
the house quickly took on a strange
stillness without his wife in it he
noticed
it felt watchful he wasn't sure he liked
it
shrugging the feeling off he went into
the kitchen and found a cutting board in
one of the cabinets
he idly wondered if it had belonged to
the old couple who had died in the house
then chastised himself for being so
morbid the silence was already beginning
to get to him he supposed
he pulled his phone from his pocket put
on some music and rested the phone on
the counter while he worked
he wasn't sure how long it had been
before he began to notice another sound
underpinning the music he stopped
chopping and reached over to turn off
the phone
at first he heard nothing but then it
came again a soft creaking sound
similar to the one they'd heard at deb's
house the day before
it was coming from somewhere below him
he put down the knife and took a few
steps toward the living room
the creaking was louder now more
distinct a regular sound
like footsteps adam turned and picked
the knife back up
feeling slightly ridiculous even though
the kitchen was warm with lake filtered
sunlight pouring in the windows
he was suddenly shivering he peered
around the corner into the living room
the palm of his hand slick on the knife
handle
a million thoughts coursed through his
head a ghostly old people of the
infamous marcus of island folk in their
strange ways
the living room was empty but there was
a definite heaviness there
as of a presence somewhere just unseen
the creaking was growing closer jesus
[ __ ] this adam said and stomped into the
living room who is that
the creaking stopped the silence
stretched out so long that adam was
beginning to think he had imagined it
although the feeling of a presence
lingered he was on the verge of turning
around
and chalking it all up to nerves when he
caught a movement in the shadows
there was someone in the hall on the
other side of the living room
beads of sweat popped out all over his
body he raised the knife
a face peered slowly around the corner
of the doorway
the face was pale and framed with curly
dark hair
adam's breath caught in his throat he
squinted into the dimness
marie she stepped fully out into the
doorway
she wasn't wearing a jacket this time
and he could see her face much more
clearly
she couldn't have been more than 19
years old she was wearing a dark blue
dress that scooped low in the front
and fell to just above her knees adam
noticed that her feet were bare and
dirty
she looked at him and smiled shy and
uncertain
hi again she said adam was so surprised
to see her that he hadn't even lowered
the knife
how did you get in here she shrugged as
if the question didn't concern her
the expression on her face was
completely serene
are you all right do you need help adam
finally
realized that he was standing in the
middle of the living room brandishing a
weapon and lowered his arm
he felt his face redden no i just
thought i'd come see you
the whole experience was beginning to
take on an aspect of this surreal
and for a moment adam wondered if he was
dreaming why
marie shrugged again and her smile grew
wider
she took a step forward into the room
her footsteps creaked on the wooden
floorboards
adam wasn't sure what to say or how to
process what was happening
you shouldn't be in here she took
another step towards him
why not your wife isn't here is she how
did you know that what are you talking
about
he could feel the sweat beginning to
trickle down his back in cold rivulets
but the room itself seemed to have grown
warmer the juxtaposition was beginning
to make him feel dizzy and slightly ill
she came toward him her steps slow and
deliberate her curls bounced around her
face
you were so nice to me when i first saw
you she said and her head tilted to one
side
her eyes were wide and amused but there
was something strange behind them
or rather something missing they looked
empty
marie i think maybe you have the wrong
idea
he backed up a step without even
realizing he was doing it
i'll go away if you want me to she
purred but she kept moving closer
she raised her hand and extended her
fingers toward him
adam's heart was pounding so loudly that
he thought everyone on the island must
be able to hear it
her hand was only six inches from his
chest now and he realized that her
fingernails were ragged
with dirt crusted beneath them the odd
sight snapped him out of whatever
bizarre spell her presence had put him
under
he took a definitive step back and half
raised the knife again
yes please go she stopped her hands
still extended as if pleading
her smile vanished and in its place
appeared an expression so pitiful that
adam's heart lurched
i thought you liked me marie said and
the voice of a child denied a parent's
affection
i'm going to be in so much trouble from
who
she seemed so lost that adam's resolve
faltered
marie didn't answer she just dropped her
gaze from his inside
i may come back she said almost to
herself
and before adam could say another word
she had spun on her heel
and run back into the hallway from which
she had emerged
wait he started after her following the
creaking of her footsteps
but she was fast and it disappeared down
the basement stairs before he could
catch her
he had a moment to wonder whether she
had been in the basement of the house
the entire
time they'd been there before he went
wheeling down the dark stairs after her
almost losing his footing in the
unfamiliar darkness marie
stop he reached the bottom of the stairs
his breath heaving and echoing in the
hollow space
he thought he heard another creak and
then came a muted bang
as of a door being closed he called out
to her again but only silence greeted
him
swearing he began casting about for the
basement walls to find a light switch
scrabbling across the concrete his toe
met something hard and unyielding
and he howled with pain at last a switch
materialized under his searching fingers
and he flipped it savagely in the watery
light from the single overhead bulb
he saw a large square space littered
with rotting boxes and old furniture
he turned in a complete circle peering
into all the shadowed corners
barely aware of the knife he still held
in his hand
he saw no door no place the girl could
have gone nevertheless the basement was
clearly deserted
and the sensation of her presence had
dissipated
[ __ ] adam stood still in the middle of
the basement for what seemed an eternity
listening he heard nothing but the far
away lap of waves upon the lake shore
amplified by the bedrock around him at
last he turned and headed back up the
stairs
when bonnie came home from her interview
she found the kitchen clean
and chopped vegetables in plastic
containers stacked neatly in the
refrigerator in preparation for dinner
adam was nowhere to be seen she put her
purse down on the counter
baby you home his voice came to her from
what seemed a great distance
on the patio immediately sensing
something was wrong
she went through the bedroom toward the
sliding glass doors her pumps clicking
across the floor
adam was sitting in one of the patio
chairs his bare feet resting on the
railing
five empty beer bottles stood like
sentinels on the table next to him
she opened the door and leaned out adam
are you all right
he turned to her and smiled his face was
paper white beneath a thin film of
stubble
so how did it go it went fine adam but
what happened
you looked sick she approached him and
put the back of her hand to his forehead
his skin was clammy at her touch and she
thought she could feel him trembling
he laughed a nervous bark i'm not sure
what happened
it's been a weird day bonnie glanced at
the beer bottles again and sat down in
the chair beside him
leaning forward to look him fully in the
face her hand crept into his lap and she
laced her fingers through his
he gripped her hand as though he was
afraid she wasn't real
tell me she said he looked at her
his eyes were damp and roomy from the
alcohol but otherwise he seemed
completely lucid
either we have a girl hiding out in our
basement or this house is haunted
he said i can still tell deb and jim not
to come tonight
bonnie said she was standing at the
stove stir-frying the vegetables while
adam stood at the bar behind her opening
the wine
no it's all right maybe having more
people around will make things seem more
normal
he had told her exactly what had
happened and though she had understood
the strange otherworldliness of the
incident as he conveyed it
she was still convinced that a rational
explanation would soon appear
that girl seemed a little weird when we
first saw her on the causeway
bonnie was saying now being careful to
temper her words so that they didn't
sound as though she was discounting his
feelings
didn't you think the cork of the wine
bottle popped and bonnie jumped almost
dropping the spatula
yeah he said but that's the thing what
was she doing walking out there in the
dark that night
where did she go afterward and i still
don't know how she just showed up in the
house today and disappeared when i ran
after her
she looked so strange bon bonnie glanced
over her shoulder at him
he seemed to have calmed down though he
was still a touch pale
we're not familiar with the place she
pointed out maybe there's a way in
through the basement
and this girl gets her jollies sneaking
into people's houses and scaring them
half to death
maybe that's all it is he said without
much conviction
he went to the cabinet and got out four
wine glasses do you need any help with
that
adam was obviously done talking about
the girl for the time being
and bonnie's heart ached for him the
experience had clearly rattled him much
more than he was letting on
there was still one more question she
had to ask on the subject though
should we ask deb and jim about it he
didn't answer at first he just crossed
the kitchen and placed the wine glasses
on the bar
i'd rather not he finally said all right
they'll be here in a few minutes so i
guess we can start setting the table
adam returned to the cabinet and began
retrieving plates and silverware
bonnie slid the stir-fry onto a dish
next to the stove and when she had
finished she looked up at him
he smiled plates in hand and kissed the
top of her head
marie was not mentioned for the
remainder of the evening
full dark had fallen outside the windows
and the ever-present sound of moving
water punctuated the dinner conversation
which had veered from one mundane topic
to another until enough wine had been
consumed to loosen tongues to some
degree
jim who neither bonnie or adam had met
previously seemed pleasant enough
though oddly distracted all through the
meal i thought it was a bit isolated
here at first he was saying
steering a fork full of broccoli towards
his mouth i got used to it pretty fast
though
i can't imagine living anywhere else now
deb gave him a side long look that he
failed to notice
she was already on her third glass of
wine if it wasn't for all the money we
poured into this place i think i'd
eventually like to move back to the city
she said
jim didn't seem to have heard her and
bonnie saw a brief scowl across the
woman's face
there and then gone adam had noticed the
wordless exchange
too and quickly changed the subject so
is the lake safe to swim in
it looked so nice and refreshing this
morning that i was thinking of taking a
dip one of these days
deb seemed glad of the distraction it's
a little cold at this time of year and
the bottom's all gunky
not my cup of tea but it's not riddled
with pestilence or anything
go for it it's very deep in places
though
jim added intensely focused on the plate
before him
that couple that lived out by the
causeway drowned in there before our
time of course
i think it was sometime last summer but
the others told me about it
bonnie sighed it seemed as though every
tendril of conversation was going to
spiral toward the macabre sooner or
later tonight
and she felt powerless to prevent it
perhaps the island had that effect
how did they drown if you couldn't beat
them might as well join them
bonnie thought grimly boat overturned
that's all
they were too far from the shore to swim
back and the water was deep
they weren't spring chickens i hear
didn't they call for help
adam still had half a plate of food
before him but bonnie noticed that he
was no longer eating
just pushing the vegetables around with
his fork i would imagine so
sound doesn't carry that far in the
water though i guess maybe no one heard
them
i don't really know much about it bonnie
turned to deb
who was staring hard into her wine glass
this was marcus's parents
bonnie said deb's gaze flicked up as
though she was snapping out of a trance
oh yeah hell of a thing leaving that boy
to fend for himself
she smirked though i suppose he's doing
all right considering
an awkward silence fell over the table
then and everyone went back to
concentrating on their food and drink
after a few endless minutes adam rose
from his chair
if you're done you can hand the plates
over we've got carrot cake and some
fresh coffee if anyone wants it
i would deb said half standing need help
with anything or
no we've got it said bonnie she stood
and collected deb's plate which had been
scraped nearly clean
gym cake and coffee sure sounds good
bonnie followed adam into the kitchen
they didn't speak to each other as they
prepared the desserts and poured the
steaming mugs
they didn't have to talk each knew what
the other was thinking
when they returned to the dining room it
was clear that jim and deb had not
spoken either
but for quite different reasons bonnie
felt a knot in her stomach
wondering if this had all been a mistake
but determined not to let the
uncomfortable vibe spoil
the evening or the remainder of their
vacation
here we are she said a little too
brightly and set the plates and mugs in
front of their guests
jim made polite noises as he dug into
his dessert and deb repeated them
smiling tightly bonnie suddenly felt a
wave of pity for the woman and gave her
a genuine smile in return
trying to communicate her feelings with
her eyes deb seemed to understand and
appreciate the gesture
nodding slightly as she sipped her
coffee after they had eaten and made a
few more half-hearted attempts at
conversation
jim stretched theatrically and reached
for the sweater that he'd hung on the
back of his chair
i should probably be getting deb home to
bed she's had a few over her limit i
think
i'm fine jim we should stay and help
them clean up
oh please don't bother with that adam
said you guys must be tired
yeah exhausted plus i still have some
things to do when i get home
this was fantastic though thanks for
having us over maybe we can return the
favor before you two leave
that would be nice bonnie said hoping it
didn't sound too insincere
another evening in the presence of the
muellers wasn't a very appealing
prospect at the moment
though of course she would endure it for
politeness's sake if she had to
she had the distinct feeling she
wouldn't have to though
upsy daisy said jim gripping his wife's
arm and pulling her up
deb made a face and was obviously about
to make a sharp remark
but refrained with a visible effort
everything was really
good thank you deb was slightly unsteady
on her feet and allowed herself to be
steered toward the front door
leaning away from her husband as she
walked adam and bonnie followed close
behind them
exchanging a glance when jim and deb
were
outside on the porch deb turned don't be
a stranger
she said looking at bonnie and then at
adam with something like longing
another wrench of pity clutched at
bonnie's chest and she placed her hand
on adam's back
stroking at his shirt with her fingers
we won't bonnie said
and meant it they left the dishes in the
sink to be dealt with in the morning
and went to bed early eyelids heavy with
wine
the sex was slow but urgent and
afterwards adam fell into a fitful sleep
while bonnie lay awake tucked into the
crook of his arm and staring out of the
glass doors at the moon glimmering water
the red numbers on the clock read 219
and bonnie still felt jittery and
supernaturally alert
part of it was the strange experience
they'd had at dinner and adam's
encounter with marie
and the job interview she was sure she
had aced but she didn't think that was
all of it
there seemed to be a sort of weight on
the air as of expectation
of impending arrival she shivered and
nestled in closer to adam
maybe his theory about a haunting wasn't
so far-fetched after all
though she chided herself for
entertaining the idea
whatever the explanation for the
occurrences was she thought one thing
was certain even if she got the job she
wouldn't be petitioning to purchase this
house
or any other on the island it was not a
hostile place she felt
but one tainted by bitterness loneliness
and secrecy
another half an hour passed in this
limbo state until finally bonnie felt as
though she might be close to dozing off
but it also seemed as if something
outside herself was preventing her from
doing so
something wanted her to wait this was
ludicrous she knew
but the sensation persisted grumpily she
squeezed her eyes shut
only to have them snap open again a
moment later when she thought she heard
a furtive sound
from somewhere outside the bedroom
window she sat up
adam rolled over and mumbled in his
sleep but didn't wake
bonnie stayed very still and listened
she wasn't exactly afraid
not yet but all of her senses had
sharpened
the sound was repeated a soft rustle and
a crack
like movement through a hedge it was
probably just an animal she thought
someone's pet scrounging around in the
underbrush outside
carefully she slid out of bed and went
to the glass doors
checking to make sure the lock was
engaged and the wooden brace wedged into
the track
she looked out across the balcony
railing seeing nothing but treetops and
shoreline
she stood there so long that adam was
awakened by her absence
bon what's the matter he asked in a
sleep fuzzed voice
i thought i heard something out there i
guess it was just an animal
come back to bed she turned to comply
suddenly cold and intensely aware of her
nakedness
there in the small circular window said
in the wall above the headboard
she saw a terrible face staring back at
her
she barely had time to register its
presence and open her mouth to speak
when it vanished into the night
there was another brief rustling from
the bushes outside and then silence
the next morning bonnie stayed in the
shower much longer than usual
trying to wash away the grime of that
awful gaze upon her flesh
for of course the nighttime visitor had
been marcus who else could it have been
deb had told them he'd been known to
lurk around spying on the women of the
island
even though he was apparently not right
in the head and perhaps not entirely
responsible for his actions
the look he had given her through the
window still felt violating
polluting she let the hot water course
over her until her skin was pink and
partially parboiled
we should leave today adam said he was
frying eggs and bacon while bonnie stood
on the periphery of the kitchen in her
robe
rubbing her hair vigorously with a towel
we can spend the rest of our vacation
somewhere else
maybe get a nice hotel in town it's such
a shame
bonnie said thoughtfully it's a
beautiful place too bad the people have
to ruin it
that's the way it usually works isn't it
he chuckled
sounding almost like his normal self and
slid eggs onto a plate that he then
handed to his wife
we can start packing up after breakfast
if you want i don't suppose we'll get
any of the rental fee back
but not much we can do about that we can
stop by the realty office on the way
into town
tell them what happened maybe they'll
give us a break
bonnie stuck a fork into her eggs and
watched the yolk work its way slowly
across her plate
like an encroachment of creeping lava
suddenly she wasn't hungry anymore
couldn't hurt but i wouldn't count on it
we'll be all right bon
i know you got that job and everything's
going to be better
i know she didn't know not really
she had been so sure of herself
yesterday but everything that happened
after she got home had her questioning
herself
scrutinizing every detail when the
breakfast dishes had been washed and put
away
they dressed quickly and began gathering
their things they hadn't brought much
but it still took the better part of an
hour
perhaps because they were both on some
level reluctant to leave
bonnie couldn't imagine why this would
be but she knew adam felt it too
it was in the way he moved like someone
in the throes of a beguiling dream
maybe it was just that feeling of
disappointment of wanting to salvage the
relaxing holiday they'd planned despite
the setbacks
but bonnie thought there might be
another reason something to do with
unfinished business
of mysteries still unsolved things about
the island nagged at her like a
persistent itch
bonnie went to the kitchen to retrieve
the remaining food items and wine they
wanted to take back
and adam hefted their two suitcases and
carried them out to the car
the day was spectacular cool but bright
and adam felt another twinge as he
glanced
out at the water and thought of powering
his way through the waves feeling the
icy droplets sloughing across his skin
the pleasant vision soon darkened though
as he remembered jim's words about the
drowning
and helplessly pictured a rotting and
algae spotted hand reaching up from the
depths to close around his ankle
frowning he threw the cases into the
trunk and slammed it shut
not leaving already are you it was a
man's voice
and one he didn't recognize i hadn't
even had the chance to meet you yet
adam turned and saw a round-faced
balding man making his way up the drive
with a basket swinging from one hand
something came up and were cutting the
vacation short unfortunately
adam powell frank klasky jillian's
husband
oh right we haven't met your wife either
but deb told us about the others on the
island
the two men shook hands too bad you're
leaving so
soon frank said it's really great here
isn't it oh these are for you
jillian made them he held the basket out
thanks that's very kind adam peeked
under the cloth and saw a small mountain
of chocolate chip cookies
when he looked back up frank was staring
at him with an odd intensity
as though studying him like a specimen
adam blinked
um thanks again and thank your wife for
us you really didn't have to give us
anything
hell not often we see new faces on the
island you're the first since deb and
jim moved in
frank said adam kept hoping that the man
would say his goodbyes and take his
leave
but he just stood there as if waiting
for something
at last adam relented do you want to
come in for a minute
i think most of our stuff is packed up
but i can probably scare you up a beer
this seemed to be what frank had been
expecting because he smiled broadly and
clapped at him on the back
sure i can spare a minute i know you're
probably in a rush to get going but i
just wanted to chat for a few
just tell me if i'm being pushy not at
all
come on inside with an inward sigh adam
headed for the house with the smell of
the cookies wafting up into his nostrils
they met bonnie in the foyer as she was
going toward the front door her arms
laden with plastic grocery bags
oh hi she said giving adam a quizzical
look
adam made the introductions and bonnie
put all the bags down next to the door
rummaging around in them until she came
up with three beers
they sat at the bar the basket of
cookies before them
thinking of moving here permanently
frank asked he had helped himself to a
handful of the cookies and was feeding
them into his mouth one by one
chewing and swallowing without apparent
enjoyment or distaste
not to the island no bonnie said firmly
maybe a place in town if i get work here
i know how the island seems when you
first get here frank was leaning forward
like a conspirator
still chewing i thought i was gonna go
bat [ __ ] the first couple years
excuse the language he shot bonnie as
simpering grin but it's gotten a lot
better
now i can't picture being anywhere else
adam remembered jim saying almost the
exact same thing and had a moment of
dislocation
two words popped into his brain and
those two words were
stepford husbands bonnie took a long
pull from her beer and propped her elbow
on the bar
i just don't think it would suit us she
said sure i gotcha
my wife sometimes talks about moving
back but i don't think she'd ever do it
women am i right he raised his eyebrows
at adam who gave him a faint smile
well we've been wanting to get on the
road while there was still plenty of
daylight
so bonnie stood up and threw her beer
bottle in the trash
thanks for the cookies that was really
thoughtful
for a moment it seemed that frank wasn't
going to move from his stool
and adam had a brief second of panic but
then he got to his feet
no problem we like to be neighborly
shame you couldn't drop by the house
thank jillian in person
she'd like that adam had the distinct
impression that he was being subtly
coerced
and felt his eye rising what the hell
was wrong with everyone around here
sorry we'd love to but we're a little
pressed for time running behind already
he managed to keep his voice level but
it was difficult hey no hard
feelings look i'll even carry those bags
out to the car for you
that's not necessary bonnie said but
frank waved a hand at her
i insist adam and me will get this stuff
and you can find something to put the
cookies in take them with you you can
eat them on the road
now bonnie was the one having to hold
her tongue she'd attested being ordered
around
however jovially but it seemed churlish
to argue and they'd be far away from
this island soon enough
so she forced a smile okay just put all
the bags on the floor in the back and
try not to crush anything
when the men were outside loading the
bags frank looked up at adam from across
the back seat
his eyes were glinting have you met her
yet
his voice was a stage whisper adam
raised his head so suddenly that he
bumped it on the ceiling upholstery
matt who you know marie
adam's eyes narrowed this whole thing
was starting to feel like a setup
who is she he asked it seemed a neutral
response
frank smirked i know you've seen her i
can tell from your face
she's something isn't she adam wasn't
quite sure how to proceed
so he just gave a non-committal grunt
that could have been positive or
negative
frank laughed it's cool man i'm not
gonna nark on you i know how it is
so did she just turn up the day you got
here maybe while your wife was out of
the house
adam could feel his heart slamming
against his rib cage and vaguely
wondered what was taking bonnie so long
what exactly are you talking about
he said finley okay okay if you want to
be all covert about it
but that's what marie does for us man
you want her and poof
there she is she just and here he made a
spider-like gesture with his
outstretched fingers
crawls out of the woodwork so to speak i
don't understand
adam suddenly felt that the interior of
the car was too close and hot
and he backed out of the open door and
stood upright he wasn't sure he wanted
to continue the conversation
frank backed out of the car too and
looked at him across the roof
his face split into a smile so large it
resembled the toothed maw of a
jack-o'-lantern
you don't have to understand adam it's
all good nothing wrong with it at all
but who is she the desperation in his
voice disturbed him
the sunlight reflecting off the water
blinded him for a moment so that frank's
face was nothing but a sparkling blur
does it matter man the blur resolved
itself into frank's features again
and adam saw that the man was still
grinning at him like a vaguely
malevolent idiot
here are the cookies it was bonnie
suddenly present beside him adam took
the container from her hand almost
shaking with relief
what are you guys talking about ah just
boring guy [ __ ] you know
frank slipped out of a wink and adam
felt his bowels clinch
anyway nice to meet you two maybe you'll
be back one day yeah
sure maybe adam realized he was still
standing there with the cookies in his
hand
he tossed the container unceremoniously
into the back seat
thanks again my pleasure neighbor
with a salute frank turned his
substantial bulk toward the road and
toddled off down the drive
when he was out of sight adam took a
deep breath and answered bonnie's
unspoken question
i think everyone on this island might be
slightly insane he said
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
it was the matter of 15 minutes to
finish packing everything into the car
and reverse out onto the island's only
road
adam could sense that bonnie was waiting
for him to speak but he kept silent
until the car's tires had left the stony
soil of the island
and gripped the asphalt of the causeway
over the water
the tunnel of trees that marked the
mainland somehow seemed a long way off
even in the clear daylight bonnie leaned
back in her seat
casting the occasional glance toward her
husband
when he finally spoke it was without
preamble he asked if i'd seen marie
bonnie looked at him sharply and and not
much more than that
he wouldn't really tell me anything
about her but i think he was implying
he paused what had frank been implying
was it what he thought it was or had the
whole thing just been a
misinterpretation of his overwrought
imagination
implying what so she is a real person
then
adam was surprised that bonnie's words
held no sense of vindication
only relief so she hadn't been entirely
sure either
i don't know the way he talked about her
it could have gone either way
if that makes any sense it doesn't what
did he say
exactly just that she would come when
you wanted her
he said that she crawled out [ __ ] he
slammed the brakes on hard
just yards from the mouth of the tunnel
bonnie didn't have to ask why he had
done it
the girl lay in a crumpled heap
partially on the shoulder and partially
in the road
the car tire had halted mere inches from
her head
adam and bonnie both jumped from the car
leaving the doors wide open
marie moved as they approached her
groaning as if in terrible anguish
she was clad in the same short blue
dress she'd been wearing on the
afternoon she'd appeared in the rental
house
and her feet were still bare and crusted
with mud and leaves
the dress was hyped up nearly to her
waist and adam noticed with combined
arousal and horror that she was
completely naked underneath
please help me the girl whispered when
they bent over her
take me away from here you're going to
be all right
bonnie said smoothing the girl's skirt
over her thighs
are you hurt can we carry you i got away
she said and her head lulled on her neck
adam was afraid she might be delirious
let's get her in the car he said to his
wife and slid his hands under her
shoulders while bonnie lifted her feet
we'll get you to a hospital marie
everything's all right now
where is he where is he marie was
suddenly panicked
thrashing a little and turning her head
from side to side
be still we've got you bonnie said
though she was struggling to keep the
girl in her grip
she looked helplessly at her husband
where is who
adam tightened his hold around her
shoulders but she was slippery as an eel
and before he could stop her she had
broken free of their grip and fallen to
her knees on the asphalt
she leaped to her feet lightning quick
her eyes darting from side to side like
a hunted animal
her knees were scraped and oozing blood
she backed away from them
her gaze unfocused she put her hands up
palms outward as if to ward them off
what's the matter with her adam bonnie
took a few steps toward the girl but
marie's muscles tensed as though she was
preparing to bolt
bonnie stopped and raised her hands and
surrender i'm just going in the car
to get my cell phone she said in a
soothing voice that was nonetheless
edged with panic
we're going to call an ambulance marie
seemed to consider this
adam was watching her face in her body
language as she stood there
and very slowly a strange calm began to
descend over her
her muscles relaxed the hysteria in her
eyes subsided
it was almost as though someone had
slipped her a sedative that was
overtaking her
inch by inch bonnie paused on her way to
the car
unsure of what was happening it's okay
marie said that empty serene expression
adam had seen earlier returned to her
face
everything is all right again i'm still
calling the ambulance
bonnie said and move toward the open car
door
i wouldn't called a thick male voice
adam bonnie and marie all turned in
unison
he was ambling up the causeway hands in
his pockets
even though she had only glimpsed him
briefly through a window in the middle
of the night
bonnie immediately recognized his oddly
lopsided features
his obsidian black eyes embedded in
their doughy white sockets
marcus there's nothing that matter with
her
she just has what do you call them
episodes
each word that came out of his mouth was
a perfectly articulated deliberate sound
as though he was speaking a foreign
language bonnie immediately saw why deb
had called him slow
but the look in his eyes and the way he
carried himself suggested the opposite
what's wrong with her bonnie was halfway
between adam and her cell phone and her
gaze flickered back and forth nervously
she knows she's not supposed to be out
here marcus said which wasn't really an
answer
she might hurt herself as he spoke he
walked up beside the girl and put a hand
on her arm
adam took a step forward unsure of
whether he should protect her
but marie just looked over at marcus
adoringly and stayed still
what's going on here adam's breath was
ragged
nothing that's any of your business
marcus said
it wasn't said in a threatening way but
a cold finger of fear still shuddered up
adam's spine
adam let's just go bonnie said he's
right it's none of our business
marcus's laconic gaze slid over to
consider her from head to toe
i wouldn't mind if you wanted to make it
your business what
adam took another step forward now wait
a minute
you're a beautiful woman bonnie all the
women on the island are beautiful
but adam let's go
no don't go yet before anyone could
blink
marcus had pulled a pistol out of his
pocket and fired
bonnie screamed and instinctively ducked
at the sound and then heard a sickening
thud just behind her
she was too frightened to turn all she
could do was stand in shock
her hands frozen halfway to her ears
you two are going to help me put him in
the car marcus said calmly
i don't need him but i can't just leave
him out here on the road
bonnie watched as marie blissfully
glided past her and felt as though she
had stepped into a surrealist film
she stared into marcus's face and then
into the barrel of the pistol that was
now pointed at her
she just couldn't seem to make sense of
anything that was happening
it will be easier if you just do what
you're told marcus's voice was almost
gentle
i don't want to hurt you but i will if i
have to
he waved the pistol toward the car and
bonnie's gaze followed the barrel
the front end of the car was fanned with
blood
all she could see of adam was his
splayed legs the rest of his body was
hidden by the open car door
she couldn't tell whether he was dead or
alive
as if in a dream she walked around the
car and looked down
adam's eyes were open and stared
unseeing at the sky
below his chin his neck was nothing but
a thick red stew of ligaments and gore
she couldn't look away until marcus
poked her in the small of the back with
the pistol barrel
come on you get that end he doesn't look
that heavy
he smirked as though he just made a
particularly clever joke
adam's blood was slick on her hands his
body made a ghastly squelching sound as
she and the oddly placid marine lifted
him
and staggered to the car with his weight
hammocked between them
under marcus's watchful eye they managed
to slide the meat that had once been her
husband into the back
bonnie had a moment to consider the
horror of what she had just done
before there was a sharp crack to the
back of her head and she was gone for a
little while
it was dark when she awakened and she
could hear voices somewhere close by
a smell hit her of fresh blood and mold
a fetid closeness
she tried to move but neither her arms
nor legs would respond
and her head was a galaxy of agony when
she tried to turn it
she was lying on a firm bed and she
thought she could make out a ceiling far
above her
punctuated with heavy wooden beams she
was debating the merits of either
screaming for help or going back to
sleep and hoping that this would all be
a dream she would eventually
wake up from when she heard a door open
and close
she stayed very still marcus's crooked
face appeared above her
and he smiled with something almost like
kindness
there was a shuffling and marie appeared
beside him like a curious child
peering around his shoulder bonnie tried
to make eye contact with her to try to
communicate but there was nothing behind
the girl's eyes for her to latch onto
they looked like a doll's eyes what is
this
bonnie managed to choke out where's adam
with my parents marcus said offhandedly
he wasn't necessary
at first bonnie had no idea what he
meant but then she remembered jim's
pronouncement at that awkward dinner
party last night
had it been only last night it seemed
impossible
her eyes filled with tears that spilled
freely down the sides of her face
i don't like unnecessary things as if to
punctuate this statement he raised a
hand and stroked
it across marie's cheek marie closed her
eyes as if in ecstasy
i'm not sure if this one here is still
necessary
what are you talking about bonnie didn't
know if she was more disturbed by what
marcus had said
or the fact that marie didn't react to
it at all
well i have you now sobs welled up
and bonnie could do nothing to stifle
them she struggled against her bonds but
whatever was holding her didn't yield
both marcus and marie were looking at
her with mildly amused expressions on
their faces
which somehow made the whole situation
even more horrific
bonnie screamed but her own voice just
echoed uselessly back to her
her captor's expressions didn't change
at all
bonnie closed her eyes and began to weep
quietly
when she opened her eyes a few moments
later the pair was still standing in the
exact same pose
as though they were made of wax at last
marcus turned to marie
i have some thinking to do go visit one
of your friends
marie nodded and turned smartly on her
heel bonnie couldn't see where she had
gone
but she heard the creak of a different
door opening and closing
and then a scrabbling sound as a
fingernail scratching through earth
there are tunnels running all underneath
this island marcus said conversationally
i don't think anyone even remembers
their here but me
he sat down on the edge of the bed
bonnie tried to stretch her body away
from him but could
not the warmth of his flesh against her
side was sickening
what do you think bonnie do you think my
sister is necessary
would you be jealous if i kept her
around curious as to how you feel about
it
bonnie simply stared at him she had no
idea what he was getting at and no idea
how to answer
i know you're not in the best frame of
mind right now i'm not either to be
honest
i don't really like how things have
turned out i guess they had to turn out
this way but i'm still not happy about
it
just kill me if you're going to bonnie
closed her eyes again
you don't understand i don't want to
kill you i want you to stay with me
bonnie sneered at him in disbelief
you're going to have to kill me then
because i won't
she said it with a conviction she didn't
feel
i know it isn't good that i had to force
the situation a little bit
marcus said as though he hadn't heard
her but i was running out of options
even with marie luring all the men away
the women still wouldn't give me a
chance
i know i'm not the best looking guy but
i take care of what's mine
i deserve something don't you think i
don't know
bonnie said defeated he looked down at
her
thoughtfully for a moment as if
contemplating whether he should punish
her for what she had said
in the end he just shrugged the nice
thing about marie is that she'll do
whatever i ask
we're family we have a bond you'd
probably need more convincing though
marie was trying to get away from you
bonnie hissed
she didn't know if antagonizing him was
wise but she was past the point of
caring
far from being antagonized though marcus
actually laughed
my hold on her slips sometimes i admit
that
relationships are complicated but most
of the time i just have to
he snapped his fingers and smiled marie
would kill for me
and has how do you think i got new blood
like you onto the island
i didn't have any use for that dried up
old [ __ ] who lived in your house
marie went over there through the
tunnels and took care of it then all i
had to do was wait
and hope you're all crazy
bonnie was tired and in pain and wished
marcus would just smash her over the
head with something and get everything
over with
everyone on this island is crazy she
thought briefly of adam
of the way his face had looked staring
up into the sky with his dead eyes
and then pictured him sinking to the
bottom of the black lake to take up
residence with the other corpses
and ghosts perhaps well i can see you're
not really going to help me make a
decision about marie
he said with acai the mattress creaked
as he stood
i guess there's one thing that could tip
the odds one way or the other
he unbuckled his belt and began to
unbutton his jeans
jesus no bonnie was too weak to fight
him
too horrified to even contemplate the
implications of his actions
she was already starting to go to
another place in her head a place far
away from here
by the time he had forced himself inside
her she had blacked out
she was alone again when she woke the
pain was so
all-consuming that she had become
detached from it as though she was
standing outside herself
she was going to die here she knew and
endure unspeakable things until then
the thought held no emotion for her at
all
voices again just outside the door
marcus was speaking
though she couldn't make out the words
after a moment there was a female voice
a single word like a murmur of ascent
and then there was a muffled gunshot
bonnie closed her eyes and was lulled to
sleep by the far away lap of waves
you